pour partir de cette proposition que
nous avions fait des premiers liste et
moi j'ai envie en disant attendez il ya
un moment donné c'est ce qu'on espère la
crise sanitaire va reculer derrière nous
il faudra bien gérer ce moment pour que
on coupe pas les aides d'un seul coup
mais qu'on travaille un peu à la façon
dont on aménage cette période de
transition entre le plein au démarrage
ce qu'on souhaite tous mes mais ça sera
pas illico presto donc il ya un travail
qui est prévu une trilogue rappelé un
trilogue entre les organes son syndicat
et direction patronale jusqu'au mois de
juin pour se préparer à cette leur
sortie de cette sortie de crise on va
revenir sur tout ça dans le détail mais
le dialogue social se passe bien avec
jean castex le dialogue se passe on
n'est pas d'accord sur tout il hier moi
j'ai redit notre opposition farouche à
la réforme d'assurance chômage géraudie
que cette réforme n'était pas du tout
derrière nous mais c'était un mur devant
les demandeurs d'emploi ce qui va leur
arriver malheureusement au 1er juillet
au 1er juillet prochain donc il se passe
on n'est pas d'accord sur tout mais sur
certains sujets notamment sur les
mesures de soutien il ya des choses qui
avancent et en tout cas c'est le seul
moyen aujourd'hui pour faire valoir nos
propositions et essayer d'obtenir la
garantie jeunes universel des mesures de
soutien aux ménages ou en direction des
jeunes etc alors sur l'assurance-chômage
justement la cgt et force ouvrière ont
annoncé leur intention d'attaquer le
décret ce que le qu'est ce que veut la
faire la cfdt sur ce sujet la cfdt elle
va attendre d'avoir le décret et elle va
regarder si dans le décret il y a de
quoi attaquer au conseil d'état il ya la
volonté de combattre cette réforme
d'assurance chômage extrêmement forte
chez nous mais il faut le faire sur les
vases qu'ils soient qui soit crédible et
donc il faut attendre d'avoir le décret
nous l'avons pas encore pour regarder
sur quelle base nous pourrions attaques
et éventuellement conseil d'état mais
nous ne nous contenterons pas de ça si
jamais nous y allons nous nous avons
aussi décidé avec les associations se
d'arrêter nouvelles contre le chômage
la fondation d'action d'action
solidarité ou deux
de d'incarner ce que ce qui va se passer
au 1er juillet parce que je crois que
les citoyens ne comprennent pas en fait
ce qu'entend de se passer on est en
train de travailler sur les travailleurs
les plus précaires les chômeurs les plus
précaires et au 1er juillet ils vont
avoir des baisses de l'indemnisation par
mois de 20 à 40% et donc il va falloir
dire que c'est pas un chiffre
macro-économique c'est pas une moyenne
c'est ce sont des gens qui vont subir
ces décisions qui sont scandaleuses en
termes d'assurance chômage donc nous
nous allons incarner nous allons montrer
ses personnels et à la classe témoigner
- carnets comment appeler à témoigner à
envoyer on est en train de regarder que
par par quels moyens de communications
mais a envoyé aux décideurs ce que sont
les situations parce que je crois que ce
que vous savez cette réforme ne fait pas
elle est injuste elle est incohérente
elle est complètement anachronique mais
elle fait pas suffisamment réagir dans
la population
malheureusement on le sait bien que sur
la question de l'assurance chômage il ya
toujours un taux de passivité
extrêmement important et bien là nous
nous voulons montrer que deux campagnes
de communication on veut pas on veut pas
laisser croire que tout ça passerait se
passerait en fait sous les radars et
qu'il y aurait pas déjà impacté il va
avoir des gens profondément impactés ce
sont les travailleurs précaires qui sont
aussi les chômeurs permis tant comme on
les appelle et donc celle là on va voir
on va appeler on appel à témoignages et
on va illustrer sa regarder notamment
dans les préfectures c'est des choses
qui se regarde mais vous savez c'est pas
très pratique dans cette période
et puis encore une fois malheureusement
je crois que le gouvernement c'est pour
ça qu'ils s'entêtent à faire cette
réforme qui n'avait aucune raison de
faire objectivement dans cette période
il le fait parce qu'il sait que il ya
bientôt deux réactions qui est
malheureusement trop faible
un dernier mot sur cette réforme de
l'assurance chômage puisque vous en avez
parlé ya alors que c'était peut-être pas
prévu au début jean castex et ne bouge
pas et vous a dit qu'il était frais une
nouvelle feuille de route il prédit qu'
on était prêt à l'aide des canons sur ce
sujet là très clairement mais même moi
j'ai réagi parce qu'à un moment donné je
crois que c'est la ministre qui dit
bombe à cette réforme il ya eu une
concertation elle est derrière nous et
j'ai dit non elle n'est pas derrière
nous elle est devant elle et devant les
demandeurs d'emploi et donc mais je
crois pas que ça ils sont prêts à bouger
non évidemment on va
revenir sur les annonces dont vous
parliez hier et notamment cette prime de
1000 euros qui a donc été annoncée par
jean castex alors non pas seulement pour
les travailleurs de deuxième ligne ce
qu'on appelle à travers de deux amis une
ce sont les caissières ce sont les
éboueurs
mais pour tous les salariés en dessous
de 1,6 smic
est ce que c'est une annonce qui vous
convient ou est ce que vous dites
pour le moment c'est au bon vouloir des
entreprises il faut la rendre
obligatoire cette prime d'abord nous ce
que nous disons depuis sur les
travailleurs de ce deuxième ligne depuis
maintenant de longs mois c'est 1
il faut une reconnaissance effective de
ces travailleurs sur la durée ça veut
dire leur revalorisation de leur
carrière l'art grille salariale de la
qualité de l'emploi qu'ils occupent de
leurs conditions de travail de l'accès à
la formation professionnelle à leur
évolution correctionnel donc cette prime
ça peut pas être solde de tout compte
mais moi je suis un syndicaliste
maintenant il faut aussi et on nous le
dit là aussi depuis longtemps que les
organisations patronales assument leurs
responsabilités dans les branchies terre
que c'est trop facile de simplement
considérer qu'il faudra renvoyer au
gouvernement cette question des
travailleurs de deux ennemis ce sont les
entreprises les branches
professionnelles qui sont concernés la
distribution le nettoyage le secteur
médico-social et ses danses et ses etc
etc
l'agroalimentaire et c'est là où il faut
assumer leurs responsabilités je prends
l'agroalimentaire les négociations
salariales ont été ridiculement basse on
n'a pas signé d'accord la cfdt n'a pas
signé l'accord dans un certain nombre de
branches parce que désaccord mis les
deux minima salariaux parce que c'était
inacceptable
au bout d'un moment il faut les
contraindre et nous ce qu'ont à dire
c'est qu'il faut contraindre les
branches professionnelles à négocier
donc cette prime on va pas cracher
dessus moi je suis un syndicaliste je
sais ce que ça peut vous craignez mais
il va falloir se battre pour qu'elle
soit versée la dernière a été versée à 5
millions de salariés
donc il va falloir se battre dans les
branches il va falloir que les
agressions patronat assument leurs
responsabilités je crois que le discours
d'hier du premier ministre était assez
assez fixé en direction de ses branches
professionnelles
il faut falloir que le medef patronat
pour qu'il ya une pression au patronat
et nous nous allons maintenant on a
aussi l'outil pour aller faire pression
et est ce qui va faire la cfdt c'est se
battre pour cette prime soit versée et
se bat pour qu'il y ait des accords de
branche sur cet ex travailleurs de
seconde ligne mais pas la rendre
obligatoire alors cette prime nous nous
avons souhaité que cette prime elle soit
nous avons souhaité qu'ils aient un
droit de retour du gouverneur de l'état
si jamais les branches ne s'y engageait
pas c'est je pense que sur un certain
nombre de sujets il faut que l'état soit
plus intervenants pas de retour c'est à
dire quoi des sanctions
oui ça veut dire qu'en tout cas il ya
une contrainte beaucoup plus forte du
goût de l'état sur sur ses branches
professionnelles sap a été retenue c'est
à nous de faire ce rapport de force dans
les branches on est suffisamment
aujourd'hui représentatif dans toutes
les branches sincérité pour le faire
mais il faudra pas se contenter de cette
prime qui n'est pas rien pour les
salariés qui en bénéficieraient que je
le rappelle mais il faudra aussi se
battre pour une revalorisation des
carrières de ces îles à sucre il a été
répondu là dessus il ya eu hier une
opposition assez frontal de la part du
medef à cette prime à cette logique de
branches en disant c'est une ingérence
non ce n'est pas une ingérence c'est une
juste retour des choses de travailleurs
qui ont été exposés pendant cette
période
et aujourd'hui force est de constater
que si on prend carrefour si on prend
les les entreprises agroalimentaires
dont on a parlé si on prend sfr eh bien
il n'y a pas ce retour c'est juste
retour des choses au contraire il ya une
forme de durcissement et donc on sent
une opposition et patronales il va
falloir se battre sur le sujet mais je
crois que le ballon il est mis au bon
endroit au bon endroit ce sont les
branches professionnelles
il ya une incitation à verser une prime
il faudra que nous on en fasse une
obligation quand on se projette dans les
mois qui viennent avec le protocole
sanitaire
aujourd'hui tous les tous les salariés
qui le peuvent sont en télétravail
comment est ce que vous voyez cette
sortie du télétravail quand on a proposé
ce scénario en travaillant en dix ans
faut travailler un scénario de sortie de
crise le prévenu nie mais sur quels
sujets à l'emploi le revenu des ménages
l'évolution de la protection sociale
on avait insisté sur le travail qu'ils
ont ce qui va se passer après c'est pas
du tout ce qu'on a connu précédemment
dire qu'on sait pas comment ça va
évoluer au niveau du travail et dans le
les sujets qui sont mis sur la table de
cette concertation de ce travail ceux de
ce thriller qui va s'opérer pour
regarder comment vont se passer les mois
de juillet août septembre octobre etc
eh bien il ya la question du travail moi
je crois qu'on reviendra pas à la
normale
je crois que le télétravail va
s'installer au fils avait même que la
productivité des salariés a augmenté
fortement mais c'est ce qu'on constate
nous ce qu'on constate je vais vous dire
c'est une intensification du travail une
faiblesse des pauses c'est hier que très
peu de pauses y compris la pause pour
déjeuner etc
et puis aussi à une forme d'isolement et
de lassitude et donc ça peut pas durer
durable durée il faudra très clairement
qu'il y ait des accords de télétravail
dans les entreprises et qui a des
limites au télétravail c'est le on est
en train de faire la démonstration que
travailler c'est faire preuve d'une
compétence individuelle mais c'est aussi
la compétence collective par des
croisements parce qu'on échange parce
qu'on on confronte
mais c'est aussi un lien social
extrêmement fort et là aujourd'hui il ya
une grosse souffrance je le dis il ya
une grosse souffrance de nombre de
télétravailleurs qui se sentent
totalement isolés et qui se sentent un
peu qui vivent avec angoisse le lait moi
qui ai les semaines qui arrivent en
disant si on est content obligé de
continuer ce qui risque malheureusement
d'être le cas ça va être très compliqué
et à la sortie va pas falloir continuer
sur les mêmes bases
il va falloir se réinterroger c'est quoi
le management c'est quoi les temps de
pause les temps le temps de travail
quand on est en télétravail sont matin
il ya déjà un accord qui a été signé
entre les rebelles tenant sa venue à
céline s'était enfin un nouveau nom ça
veut dire prendre cet accord et
l'appliquer dans les branches et les
entreprises au morcellement aller plus
loin sur cet accord en fait il faut que
ce soit dans les branches et les
entreprises comprennent ans qu'on tienne
compte de l'organisation du travail
je pense que ça va ça va moi je pense
que allah à terme dans les années à
venir
ça va remettre la question de
l'organisation du travail comme un vrai
objet de dialogue social ce qui
malheureusement elle n'est pas
aujourd'hui mais c'est sur le trail est
une vécu difficilement par nombre de
travailleurs aujourd'hui et il va
perdurer il faudra qu'il soit beaucoup
plus encadré beaucoup plus aidé que
c'est dans cette période de finalement
d'urgence où il n'est pas vraiment un
mot sur les jeunes puisqu'il en a été
bien sûr question hier les aides à
l'apprentissage qui sont maintenus en
2021 et la prime à l'embauché des jeunes
qui est prolongé jusqu'au 31 mai ce sont
les annonces de jean castex est ce que
c'est suffisant pour vous
l'apprentissage c'est absolument
indispensable de continuer je crois que
c'est un des succès collectif il faut
s'en réjouir
sur la prime la prime aux jeunes al
embauche de jeunes objectivement il ya
des effets d'aubaine
donc c'est à prolonger jusqu'au 31 mai
il faudra
voir si ça nécessite de compte
poursuivre il faut pas oublier que en
juin sorte une nouvelle cohorte il
apparaît entre les entreprises qui
auraient embauché et qui embaucherait
mais c'est pour comme toute aide à
l'embauché
il faudra quand même prendre conscience
qu'il ya encore huit cent mille jeunes
qui arrivent sur le marché du travail en
juin prochain et que les 800000 qui sont
arrivés en juin dernier sont loin d'être
tous en emploi nous hier sur les jeunes
on a insisté aussi sur ceux garantis
jeunes universel c'est à dire ou rsa
jade on l'appelle comme on veut c'est à
dire cette capacitéà a donné une
allocation aux jeunes qui sont le en
difficulté ce soit ou un droit ouvert à
toutes et à tous tous les jeunes et un
accompagnement qui va avec qu'ils soient
fournis par la mission locale pôle
emploi l'apec des associations mais en
gros con qu'on comprenne davantage le
2-2 de consistance dans l'accompagnement
des jeunes il ya des choses qui sont
faites vous l'avez dit mais je crois
qu'on peut aller beaucoup plus loin
c'est ce qu'on a dit encore il ya sur le
rsa jeunes le gouvernement ferme
toujours la porte sous cette appellation
là ça me parait oui il ferme la porte on
parle de concertation sur la garantie
jeunes universel si la seule garantie
jeunes universel s'est ouvert à tous les
jeunes qui le demande qui sera en
difficulté d'emploi ouvert avec une
allocation qui soit du niveau du rsa et
un accompagnement si ça s'appelle
garantie ggn universelle je prends mais
on en n'est pas là pour l'instant on va
parler justement de l'après crise est ce
que le gouvernement vous en a dit plus
sur un calendrier de levée des mesures
sanitaires ou est ce qu'il vous a dit
que c'était trop tôt
non on s'est trop tôt d'ailleurs c'est
quand on a discuté de l'après crise
hier on s'est dit il ya une forme de
forme d'anachronisme puisque on est
plutôt sur l'idée que sans que j'en
sache beaucoup beaucoup plus que nous et
ça ne vaut pas plus que vous sur une
l'idée de peut-être un durcissement un
certain nombre de règles dans les jours
à venir
et en même temps parle de l'après crise
mais ça se prépare tout ça mais on ne
sait pas quand est ce que les
restrictions seront levés pour
accompagner cette sortie de crise vous
vous défendez la mise en place d'une
taxe exceptionnelle sur les plus plus
ou revenu qui pourrait être concerné à
partir de quel niveau je crois moi je
crois qu'il ya deux niveaux il ya deux
choses qu'il faut faire pour accompagner
financièrement a sauté crise et oui il
faut tous ceux qui ont profité de cette
période notamment pour augmenter leurs
revenus et je pense là aux très hauts
revenus de façon peut-être symbolique
parce que savent que ça couvrira pas
tous les besoins mais de les faire
contribuer davantage ça me paraît
absolument indispensable y compris en
termes de sens démocratique d'efforts
partagés et on sait que dans un certain
nombre de très très hauts revenus les
lélés dernier décile comme on dit ils
ont profité de cette crise pour
s'enrichir encore un peu plus ce serait
pas anormal de leur distribuer et donc
et une taxe exceptionnelle
je crois aussi qu'on a à s'interroger
sur l'epargne l'épargné des français
d'une partie des français et pas de tout
ça de l'epargne de pied alors à quel
niveau
et bien non de tous ceux qui ont pu
pouvoir et parier qu'on puisse leur
possible donner la possibilité de
l'investir dans la transition écologique
de l'investir dans les solidarités moi
je crois que voulaient au chai dans les
pannes des français n'ont pas piocher
leur permettent de l'utiliser à bon
escient pour orienter vers un autre
modèle de développement qui serait la
treille sur l'écologie qu'est la lutte
contre les inégalités
fais moi je crois que il va ya la
question économique social ya tous les
sujets convient d'évoquer et la sortie
de crise
elle va être magnifique eva c'est aussi
se manifester par un besoin de commun
quel horizon commun qu'est ce qu'on va
faire ensemble et ça ne se passera pas
autrement que par des logiques de
solidarité il ya un autre schéma qui est
chacun pour soi et on fait on reprend un
peu de respiration parce qu'on lève la
liberté les restrictions des libertés
mais mais on réfléchit pas ce qu'on veut
construire en commun et sa voix si on
fait un serre ce schéma là c'est très
dangereux
c'est très dangereux démocratiquement
faut qu'on se le dise par contre il ya
je crois que oui à tout un tas de gens
qui ont épargné
il n'est pas qu'ils sont de leur prendre
mais il est pas qu'ils sont non plus
d'avoir comme seule logique de libérer
la transmission la transmission de
patrimoine comme s'est proposée par
bercy aujourd'hui ça veut dire que les
riches peuvent donner à leurs enfants
pour que même moi je pense qu'il faut
aussi avoir une logique de solidarité
je sais pas c'est un appel un appel par
exemple à financer davantage le
mouvement le
les associations qui sont aujourd'hui
nous des vrais vecteurs de solidarité
dans notre pays et qui est qui sont en
grande souffrance parce que manque de
bénévoles difficultés de don aujourd'hui
fabrice qui n'a pas besoin de redonner
un sens à ce qu est quand même le rôle
d'une société c'est à dire de faire vu
des solides du premier ministre sur
cette taxe exceptionnelle que vous
proférez il ya on sent bien jeu il n'y a
pas eu hier de réponse spécifique sur ce
sujet on sent bien très clairement que
c'est pas c'est pas la politique qui est
suivi depuis 2010 est je lui dis on est
plus en 2017 alors en 2017 je pensais
déjà qu'il fallait une réforme de la
fiscalité une contribution davantage les
plus hauts revenus des revenus du
capital
a fortiori aujourd'hui de façon
exceptionnelle pour paul pour l'instant
on va pas se lancer dans une réforme
fiscale à un an des élections
présidentielles
mais pour le moins une vraie taxe sur
les plus hauts revenus et ce serait ça
aurait du sens je crois que ça donnerait
la démonstration à des français qui
objectivement en bave à des travailleurs
qui ont été présents très présent qu'on
travaillait plus y compris en
télétravail que l'effort est partagé
aujourd'hui attention à ce que ce
sentiment de d'une sécession des plus
aisés des plus riches ne s'ancre pas
dans la dans la population avec beaucoup
de ressentiment il n'aurait pas
forcément tort légende concert pourrait
donner quoi vous nous parliez d'un
risque démocratique tout à leur voile
aux risques démocratique on le sait
qu'on le connaît c'est à dire une espèce
de rejet de tout et de et de conte et le
fait de considérer que le rassemblement
national sera juste un aléas de
l'histoire et qu' il se serait pas si
grave que ça moi je crois que ce risque
là ils existent comme il existe une
forme de fracturation de la société et
que toute société qui se fracturent ou
toute société qui devient un petit kiki
qui tombe vers le totalitarisme
ce sont les plus fragiles qui qui
trinquent les plus fragiles ceux qui
sont le plus exclus les de la recherche
de boucs émissaires on sait ce que ça
peut donner
et ce sont finalement aussi nos libertés
nos libertés collectives et
individuelles qui en client souffrirait
donc on peut éviter ça mais il faut
éviter ça en redonnant du sens commun et
en redonnant un peu de notions de
solidarité de son fraternité un peu de
sens et dans la sortie de crise il va
jouer beaucoup de ça beaucoup de ça on
va tous se retourner
bat avec nos amis refaire la fête c'est
mais peut-être qu'il faudrait qu'on
s'interroge aussi sur la société qu'on
veut construire c'est pas antinomique
avec le reste moi je ferais je n'espère
j'aspire à ça mais je pense que il faut
vraiment se re d'opposer la question de
ce que devra être la société demain et
la contribution des uns et des autres et
un dernier mot sur cette sortie de crise
avant de passer à différentes questions
d'actualité hier dans le journal les
échos vous proposait de confier à six ou
huit personnes la mission de dresser un
panorama de la situation afin de
construire des scénarios de sortie de
crise est ce que cette proposition elle
a été retenue par le premier ministre
pour un nom pour l'instant ça veut pas
dire qu aura pas d des liens avec des
travaux d'experts pour l'instant c'est
plutôt l'adema la méthode proposée par
le prémunit c'est plutôt les
organisations syndicales et direction
patronales et et les laits le
gouvernement le ministère du travail oui
ça m a créé et matignon
moi je pense qu'on aura besoin d'écouté
par exemple en ce moment j'écoute
beaucoup évidemment ce que disent des
économistes mais ce que disent des
sociologues ce que disent les
psychologues beaucoup d'inquiétude
aujourd'hui sur l'état psychologique du
pays des citoyens et on aurait besoin je
crois de ça c'est d'eux que ça infuse un
peu et on a on n'a pas le choix là dans
les fonctions qui sont les nôtres des
responsables syndicaux mais aussi google
patronaux et gouvernementaux
il faut qu'on agisse la question n'est
pas d'être le relais simplement de
difficultés il y en a beaucoup beaucoup
trop
elle est aussi d'essayer de trouver des
solutions et là on a des experts moi
j'avais des mois de mars dernier
il ya un an fait proposé la mise en
place d'un comité d'experts en sciences
sociales pour regarder comment à
traverser cette épreuve
ça avait été balayé en disant c'est
encore une idée fumeuse la cfdt
n'empêche que on y est on est dans un
aujourd'hui beaucoup de problématiques
sociétales qui sont posées on aurait
besoin de s'appuyer sur beaucoup de
beaucoup d'experts en la matière
différents sujets d'actualité pour
éliminer on va commencer par danone
peut-être oui alors l'éviction de
d'emmanuel faber delà de la présidence
de danone est ce que c'est un sujet qui
vous inquiète sachant que c'était
atteindre un président qui était très
engagé dans la transition écologique et
sociale qu'est-ce qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
6 d'abord nous on était très attaché à
la gouvernance à veut pas dire qu'on est
attaché à l'homme même si moi j'ai
beaucoup d'estimé pour pour le faber la
gouvernance était quoi c'était
simplement que c'est être considéré
qu'une entreprise c'est pas simplement
un but un but de rentabilité à tout crin
c'est ça aussi une responsabilité
sociale et environnementale
si l'éviction de monsieur faber c'est la
contradiction de ce qui est
historiquement danone bouger beaucoup de
craintes par contre je veux pas faire ce
procès d'attention aux nouveaux
dirigeants
maintenant je voudrais que savoir si la
la la la la conviction que qui est celle
de danone depuis maintenant de
nombreuses années qu'une entreprise doit
faire évidemment de la rentabilité ce
qu'elle fait c'est 13 à 14% de
comptabilité ces sept dernières années
et en même temps à se préoccuper de la
façon dont sont traitées ces salariés
mais aussi ses sous traitants ses
fournisseurs et c'est donc avoir une
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale
j'aimerais savoir si ça perdure il faut
que ça perdure et moi je suis très
inquiet vous avez quand même des doutes
oui bien sûr on a en tout cas on a
beaucoup d'inquiétudes et les salariés
aujourd'hui et l'air content de la cfdt
à danone ont beaucoup d'inquiétude un
fonds activiste avec 3% peu peut
modifier complètement le gouvernement
français je pense qu'il sait jouer autre
chose à danone aussi pas simplement avec
ses fonds activistes mais c'est sûr
qu'il ya des fonds activiste je pense
que on a pas on n'en a pas fini avec
certains modèles capitalistes qui
considèrent et notamment de ces fonds
qui considère que seule la rentabilité
compte et le reste est juste anecdotique
banon je crois qu'il ya une
responsabilité de l'entreprise bien
au-delà de sa propre rentabilité est ce
qu'il faudrait que les salariés soient
mieux représentées au sein des illustres
très clairement qu'il ya besoin d'une
gouvernance autres des entreprises à
celles d'été vous le savez peuple est
pour ça depuis maintenant de nombreuses
années pour que dans les conseils
d'administration mais aussi dans le
cadre du dialogue social
les représentants des salariés davantage
de poids là on a été malheureusement
trop spectateur mais parce qu'on n'avait
pas les moyens de faire autrement il y
aurait quand même je pense que la voie
du travail soit davantage présentes dans
les instances de gouvernance de
l'entreprise c'est absolument nécessaire
à l'est c'est la démonstration que kill
kill il est urgent d'agir là dessus
l'autre actualité ce sont ces
occupations de salles de spectacles qui
se multiplient à travers la france il y
en a 50 à peu près à l'heure
elle est ce que vous encourager ce mode
d'action ou est ce que vous dites comme
roselyne bachelot que c'est inutile et
dangereux dont je crois qu'il ya le
monde du spectacle souffre c'est pas le
seul secteur à souffrir mais bien sûr il
ya une incompréhension de nous
réouverture de certains lieux culturels
pas simplement du spectacle moi je pense
par exemple sur les musées il ya une
forme d'incompréhension on est très
présent dans le secteur de la culture à
cfdt
et donc voilà après les gens ils
choisissent ce mode d'action le plus le
plus approprié pour eux donc vous
soutenez le plus si si ça se fait de
façon de façon pacifique
mais encore une fois moi je suis très
préoccupé par le monde de la culture par
le monde du spectacle suis très
préoccupé par le monde de
l'agroalimentaire par le monde de
l'aéronautique par le monde des hôtels
cafés restaurants et je crois qu'il faut
il faut qu' il faut entendre que j'ai à
vous dire très franchement ce qui s'est
passé aux césars ça donnait un petit
côté quand même très auto-centrée voilà
il faut il faut montrer que que beaucoup
de secteurs sont en difficulté qu'il
faut tous les soutenir et qu'il ne
s'oppose pas les uns aux autres donc oui
moi je suis inquiet pour le monde de la
culture
un mot sur la réforme des retraites
patrice oui alors est-ce que sur cette
réforme des retraites olivier dussopt
pts et et olivier ferrand dans un
entretien au journal les échos disent
que ça ça reste une réforme utile pour
vous est ce que est ce qu'on peut encore
discuter de des retraites avant la fin
du quinquennat
mais la mort qui est ce qu'ils
aimeraient faire qu'est-ce que la
réforme utile c'est celle de monsieur du
soft et monsieur virant celle de
monsieur le maire c'est une réforme
paramétrique c'est une réforme
qualitative
on sait plus j'ai dire là c'est une
espèce de balancer que ces ballons c'est
comme un mantra d'abord de 2,2 de deux
ministres dont on attendrait pas qu'ils
nous vante une réforme paramétrique des
retraites la clé la question des
retraites elle elle demeure parce qu'on
fera croire et interroge le système de
protection sociale pour voir comment le
faire évoluer encore une fois mais la
réforme qualitatif qu'on appelait le
nouveau c'est à dire un système
universel des retraites elle n'est pas
passable dans les mois à venir tout le
monde le sait si ce petit musique ça
veut dire que des ministres où d'autres
pensent qu'on peut faire une réforme
paramétrique des retraites c'est à dire
augmenter l'âge d'ici la fin du
quinquennat je leur dis vous êtes
dingues mais
faudra pas prendre des mesures d'urgence
un débat prénom il ya un débat
présidentiel en 2022 ou c'est ce dont on
parlait sur les retraites on parlait de
7 à 10 milliards il ya un an pour savoir
comment financer la réforme de l'avenir
des retraites
aujourd'hui c'est et on est plus dense
était pure là vous savez bien sûr les
finances publiques donc balancé le sujet
des retraites
l'agité d'ici la fin du quinquennat
j'aime je vous le dis c'est totalement
irresponsable
on est dans un pays qui est tendu si
vous mettez à la rentrée scolaire 2021
le sujet des retraites sur la table vous
avez de l'opposition à tous les étages
et c'est pas juste
il en a pas moi je ne veux pas que la
réflexion sur les retraites se limite à
savoir comment les gens travailleront
peut-être deux ou trois ans de plus ça
serait injuste totalement injuste pour
tous les travailleurs de la seconde
ligne non par exemple dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure
arrêtez avec ça malheureusement il nous
reste peu de temps en espagne le
gouvernement et les partenaires sociaux
sont tombés d'accord les ivoires à
domicile vont être considérés comme des
salariés c'est une première en europe à
ce que vous demandez qu'il en soit de
même en france est ce qu'il ya des
discussions qui vont être engagées il ya
des discussions qui sont engagés à
travers un rapport notamment sur la
représentation des travailleurs de ces
travailleurs indépendants mais très
dépendant économiquement
moi je crois qu'il ya des modèles
d'ailleurs qui se développe dans la
restauration la livraison de deux de
restauration de
2 oui de restauration il ya des modèles
avec des salariés embauchés par des
plantes par des plateformes et d'autres
qui le sont
[Musique]